the character carly very much still
loves sam
and always will and we all really wanted
jeannette to be a part of the show in
real life
but she's just doing other things and
we're really happy for
oh sam
we know that jeanette mccurdy is not
taking part in this series but
sam is still in this universe will we be
getting an explanation as to where sam
is and what her relationship status is
with carly and freddie and spencer today
yeah definitely um we talk a lot about
the sam character
and where she is in the pilot episode
yes yeah it's
your your there's the pilot touches on
it it
it will be addressed but it's
it's not something that we go
too deep into just because you know we
want to respect
jeanette's wishes you know she's decided
to move on from acting
and she's doing great in her own world
and we're super proud of her and she's
part of this family forever
and uh but that also gives us space to
sort of
get new characters in and and have new
unexpected storylines and voices and
and it's but yeah it will be addressed
the character carly
very much still loves sam and always
will
um and we all really wanted jeannette to
be a part of the show in real life but
she's just doing other things and we're
really happy for
but um but yeah we're definitely going
to touch on that in the show
is the elevator door still open that if
jeanette wanted to come back as sam for
an episode
could that happen any time i mean that
elevator door is always up it never
closed but we also but again we want to
be respectful of her and the decisions
that we made so obviously you know no
pressure
of course but whatever she wants to do
we love her that's that's all she needs
to know
icarly is experiencing technical
difficulties
welcome to the new icarly the trailer
was
so much fun and everyone is freaking out
we heard spencer say
damn it damn it but miranda the trailer
says that this is the show
that we've known and loved but now it's
all grown up how would you say that
icarly has evolved now with this new
reboot
yeah i'd say it's evolved a lot when i
started the first show
i was 13 years old and most of the
experiences and things my character was
going through on the show were things i
was going through in real life
and now i just um turned 28 and um
my character is going through all the
things you go through in your late 20s
so
it's just been really fun getting to
play the character again and getting to
see where her life has taken her
i'm really glad to hear you say that